WHINDT WE ARE DPRESIDENT W REO.
THESE ARE
BULLY SAYSOU TOSH HADHAT
WITH THE RNORS.
RT'S RI
L FROMSIDENT WING A SHEN HE WAS
NG H TOTA TRNOR WIS C
EIPECTIVESTATES WGIHA PI THESE
ARIM GUIDAE
THES RNORS DETERMINE
WHATS FOR THEM A
O SEN  OFFICIAL IT WIL
UP T GOVERNOR'S DISCRETION  REO.
LET'S MEHE
PHASES AS WE AR
IDELINES.HOULDOI
AMERICAN ALL 50 STATES WOULD
ST EAY PLA AND PHASE 1.YS, FORT
ER WILLTO
PHASE 1, WHAT DOES TINDIVIDU PL
WILL CONTINUE TORGE
URTELEWORK ANDETURNWORK O IFPHA.
AS FAR AS SCHOOLS ARE
THEY WILL REMAIN HOOLS THAT ARER
GS, THE
ADMINISTRATIONAY
SOGA STATES I
PHASE 1 SHOULD NOT BE LARGER
THAN TEN NON-ESSENTIARA SHOULD
MINIMINOW, MOV PHASE TAREE
BEYONDHA INTO PHA REERABLES, TH.
WORKPLACE,
NCOURAGEWO
BUT SOM ABLE TO RETURN
TOOR.
IN TERMS OFSCHOOLS,
WHERNGE TAKES PL
L BE ABLE TO  P
NOW, I OF SOCIALINGS, YOU AAN I
AN BAVOIDED
AT SOCTHTHAT MEANPLE WLE ABLE
DINNER PARTY GOOIES IHOMES, AS
THEY'RE NOT LARGER THAN AND NON
RESUME.
A
STATE YOU LIVE IN
2,ES, ACCORDINGGUIDES YOU
BE ABLE  VACATION
AND RESTAURANTS, BARS,GYMS, ALL.
THAT ISHA2,E NOTER YOU HAVE TO
MIRATH A
E CAN MOVE PHA 2 TO PHASET IT W
LOOK LIKE, VNERABLE SE WLA
RESTIO WTSHE RKPLACE, B
RESTS,BARS, THE
REMAIN OPENE W
PHYSICALTATIONOC
AS I WAS JUST SAYING, WOLF, I
SOUNDS WONDERFUL TO PHASE STASV
EXPECTED TO BE PRESS
CONFERENCE IN JUS ABOUT HOUR
NOW, DR. BO THEY
WILLE WALKS THEY
PRES
ORTLY.
>> T GUIDELINES A HE T
SO WHAT'S THEIN MOVE N PSE TO
PHASE 3?
>>GHT.
THAT IT NOWBODY IS
ESSENTIALL AT P 1,
COTO ADMINISTRATION.STHAT HAV N
THE COROVI WHE
YOU COMPARE THOSE STATES  LIKE
RS
BUT TO GET TO PHASE  THOSE STAT
IS GATING CRITERIA.
THATECREAS
IN CES C
14-D PHO
WO MOVE TO CUT
CRISIS CONDITIONS IN THO
IF YOU CANAT T REQUIREMENTS, T
ACCORDING TOADMINIOV PHASE 2,
THOSE AREEUND OF CORONAVIRUS CI.
SOYOU ARE SHOWING PROING IN
PHASE 1, YOU CAN PHASE  EVIDENCE
AIIK
MIRAGE FOR EVERYBODY LIVING IN
RIGHT NOW.
THE ARE FOR REGIO NO A REBOUN S
LFSS NEBULOUS
POINT.
AULT ALL OF THE
FOR P NEWOR
RSHARD-HIT STA R
NG TO BEREMELY
DIICE KNOW, FOR ST, ES
HIT MOVE F PHASE
PHASE 2 TO PHASE  THIS A LOT OFE
SELLING EARLIER ALL OF THIS TO
THE NOTASYING EARLIER TS HE WA'N
IN THATOCT JIM ACOSTA
HOUS GET B
PR REOPEINES, COENF
THENT P FORORE
TOCN  OWELATEST.
LL, WAGTNOTHER RDERE IN
CALIFOR
CALIFORNIA.
I AMOREW AREREYE THISA DRIVEHR
YO UP A KIEST YOURSELF IN YR  T,
BE BACK O NEED F  THE  T
TO TEST, , TEST.
>> WHY OPENOW BECAUSE WE'REFR
FENIL >> Reporter: WHILE WEEM
CLOSED, TMPERAMATIC A
MORE THAN   J
ANES AT FOOD 'TAVBUFFER.
THEREAFOR THESEFOLK NOSA
>> Reporter: AND NEW HO
STIL  DAILY, 1 OST THIS NEW  HO
>> OUTRAGEDHA DEAD WERE A TO PIU
MAKE-SHI AT TH
FACITY.
>> ReporteONHE WHIEW SOCIAL
WITH A REOPENING.>>THE COUNTIESY
SOON.
WE J HAVE THE TESTING. IHI THAT.
WHO THENFECTION
RATE IS.
orter: MASSACHUSETTS AND
RHODE ISLAND COULDTI DAYS
OR WEEKSAWAY FROM T MAY HAVE PAD
PEAK ANDE ARE NOW
STHA INPLACE.
MATTER
IT'S STILLANGEROUSO  AND
AHEAD OF THOSE  FEDERAL GUIDELL
ST OMONTH.
THROUGH 1L TO WEAR
S, OR RY IT MAKES PPY.
I IT A
ter: AMAZON
BEN BUILDING
SIN L SHAREHOLDERS, CEO
JE FORD
VASTLYE TESTING CAPACITY
THAN IS CURRENTLYBLE. THAT STIL.
>> GOD EP US
ONE THAT WILE WE A GET AVA AGT.
COURSE REISSUE GLI
>> AT THE END DAY, EVERY
GOVEOR MAKE UP THEIR OWN OC>> R.
YO JUST SCONSIN, THE EXTENDED M
THROUGH M 26.EDGO WERETHERSES AD
AGAIN, S GOLTHCLUBHOES
EXPECT TO SEE AREGIONIFE MOVED I